foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show we help you win in your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships all three of those
areas are connected we want you winning
in all of them the phone number to jump
in is triple eight eight two five five
two two five is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Ramsay
personalities co-piloting the ship today
I'm Ken Coleman joined by uh the the
incomparable the the lovely the gracious
graceful
next hour I'll do about three more
adjectives we'll just see if I can come
all the new edges always good to be with
you friend you as well it is summertime
the three kiddos lots of activities uh
how's it going man good summer so far
dance camp when riding her bike to
friends houses I mean they're scattered
isn't it today literally today yeah
that's great well it's good to have you
in studio uh it's always fun Rachel's
gonna help you on your money questions
and I'm here to help on your work
related questions so you know hey I'm in
a toxic situation can I get out if I'm
in the baby steps uh how do I make more
money we want to help you make more
income
so that you get through those baby steps
faster and that's why I'm here as well
with Rachel so let's get this going
Trent joins us in Chicago Illinois Trent
how can we help
woman Mrs Cruz how you doing today good
I'm glad you called her Mrs Cruz because
I thought this was going to be Mr
Coleman or Rachel and I was going to
feel like Mr Rogers the age I was gonna
feel so old good to talk to you Trent
how can we help
so um I just got engaged last month for
the love of my life and congratulations
we are planning our wedding I'm actually
going out to see a venue today but um
while getting ready to uh to take this
big step in my life I decided to run a
credit check on my fiance who doesn't
have or at least to her knowledge didn't
have any credit card didn't have any
debt and I've been following the Ramsey
plan for the past five six years so I
have no debt I've been able to cash flow
college and everything like that I'm on
my senior year so I'm almost done but um
in in pulling her credit report I found
something a little bit disturbing um
there was a credit card and her name
that showed up as having a balance of
nineteen thousand dollars whoa and so
um obviously she was she was completely
shocked by this and I was shocked by
that so
um when we went back and I confronted
her family come to find out her mom had
opened that card back in 29 19
and had I guess the entire family on it
from what she's been telling me I
haven't been able to
um to uh to corroborate that story with
the rest of the family but wow they're
she's saying that that it's kind of like
a family vacation card and then she told
me that she pays it off every month and
by tracking the uh the stuff on Credit
Karma looking at the um the credit score
and everything in the the carryover
balance I know it's not true
so now I'm in a situation I brought it
up to her she she got super defensive
told me that
um I can't live without a credit score
and the whole nine yards if I can't get
a mortgage and all that and I told her
that listen I've saved up I am I'm going
to go through manual underwriting I
don't need a credit score I don't need I
don't need that to live my life and I'm
going to be debt free for my entire life
and she's telling me that I need to find
or go to counseling financially so that
I can figure out how to take care of her
daughter since obviously I don't
understand finances so okay here for
some counseling oh my gosh we're your
counselors is that it I need a swing of
Pepto-Bismol my stomach has turned about
four times already my goodness okay so
Trent there's two elements of this
um the second element I'll just hit
first because I think it's an easy one
you're not gonna convince her otherwise
so by you guys just going back and forth
with your opinions you're not going to
convince her she's not going to convince
to you and so you have to be able to go
forward in this relationship with her
daughter and obviously your fiance needs
to be comfortable and secure enough in
you guys to say yeah whatever my mom
says because she's gonna be saying this
Trent for the next
50 years possibly you know what I mean
so like you're gonna hear this all the
time and and just making sure that you
and your fiance are on the same page
because that's all that matters right
the extended family whatever they choose
to do or what they believe that doesn't
matter as much anymore because it is
your family it's now you guys that once
you get married like it's you guys so
making sure your fiance and you are on
the same page and so not trying to sit
there and convince your mother-in-law so
that was kind of one part the end of
your call is what you were speaking of
were those arguments and that's so
frustrating and I'm really sorry about
that okay and then the first one which
is obviously the the one that majorly
um affects you and your fiance is I mean
that it's illegal she she stole her
identity is what she did and I guess
board's a signature she signed for her
and everything
yep
so what I would do is contact she she
needs to remove the balance she needs to
open up if this is if she's living the
credit card life that nineteen thousand
dollars immediately needs to be put back
in on her and in her courts and so
that's what I would say is that the next
move is that and I don't care how you do
it when you do it or no I hear when but
like how whatever Avenue you choose this
nineteen thousand dollar balance needs
to be off of my fiance's name because
she didn't do it does the mom see
anything wrong with it Trent because
here's what's messed up too is there's a
lot of there's a there's a trend going
around Ken with people opening up cards
in their kids names and doing this then
they pay bills so that they're that
their child gets a good credit score
when they turn 18. I mean there are
parents doing this now and the and the
you know the whole idea is yeah but if
they get stuck with a balance then it's
the kids responsibility then to pay it
at 18 which is just absurd so this is
exactly what's happened but she did it
in secrets so was she like does she
under does the mother like does she
take any ownership in it at all like to
say yeah there's nine there's facts that
there are nineteen thousand dollars that
you've not paid that is your bills not
your fiances
you know ma'am unfortunately she she
does not she thinks that she's helping
her out by building her credit score and
getting her started and giving her a um
at least from the conversation that I've
had with her giving her a ability to
just in case you fall into hard times
when you first get married you know what
is your fiance what does your fiance
said or done to this point with her own
mother
she's she's a little bit more of a
non-confrontational type
so and um and the mom has always kind of
run her finances and she still stays at
home with her parents hey dude your
fiance needs to close the account it's
under her name so she needs to go and
just close the account completely that's
right and if this mother keeps this
uptrend I'm like I hate to say it this
is like where where legality comes out I
mean this is like this is this is yeah
but you guys you don't have the money
Trent necessarily to go and fight your
mother-in-law in court but no but here's
the deal Trent that I'm going to tell
you this Rachel's right but you this is
a serious conversation with your fiancee
uh she has to close the account she must
confront this on some level or if I were
you my friend I'm not saying break up
with her but I would hold off on the
wedding until this stuff gets solved
between your future wife she's got to
say all right Mom boundaries here she's
got to put up some boundaries in fact uh
can we get her a copy of the book
boundaries by our dear friend Dr Henry
Cloud hang on the line I want you and
your wife to read this together this is
a fantastic book that will really help
you and while we're at it get them
necessary endings while I'm giving away
free books but this you need some help
here and you two need to be on the same
page it's dangerous dangerous territory
going forward wow thank you for the call
we're praying for you this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz this hour the phone number
for you to jump in is toll-free it is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll take your
questions related to your money of
course and then get some job and work
questions income related questions we're
here to help and taking on a topic that
I don't think is new to anybody if
you're talking about money and you're
thinking about money it's uh money
fights Rachel money fights and uh I've
been married 25 years you're how long
you in Winston hell how many years it'll
be 14. 14. so combined we've got a lot
of money fights that you and I represent
in all those years uh everybody has the
money fights and uh fascinating article
you've got headline why do couples
really fight about money what what is
going on here what do we know yeah so
this is interesting so this came out
from
psychologytoday.com and it says yeah
talk to anyone about their relationships
with their partners and you'll discover
that every every couple has
disagreements so in an attempt to
identify the contents of financial
issues uh
I said this name I said that I think the
name wrong Peach is that what you would
say yeah yeah they did a study the two
studies conducted yep two study study
one they gathered descriptions of fights
about money from posts on Reddit God God
bless you uh from this large pool of
data they were able to identify two
overreaching themes when it came to
money arguments Ken one was concerns
about fairness number two was perceived
responsibilities and many of them
identified these issues falling into
under these two overreaching themes they
list some of more of the issues down
below and then they did a second study
where they gathered data a financial
conflict from couples in a committed
relationship and two overarching themes
happened in study too concerns about
fairness and responsibility re-emerged
and additionally new con uh was mundane
expenses the conflict of that which was
related to disagreements about Minor
purchases such as how much money you
should spend on a birthday party oh 100
or yeah who can pay for uh
Camp related expenses so care really
yeah no car related expenses so here's
the thing I identify with that one
because we joked about this I think last
time we were on the air I get a little
irritated at Stacy spending money on
like little gifts
um
I am a giver but women just find reasons
to buy gifts you know and so I remember
early on now it's not a big deal I'm
talking early on when we were really
trying to figure out sure I'm talking
early in marriage yes listen I said I've
been married 25 years I've long since
learned to let that go or I wouldn't be
married this long Okay so this was a
long time ago but I do remember that
like little things like well we're
spending this much on this little party
there's another one that got us when the
kids were little they get invited a
birthday party you're in the thick of
this now or you're getting in at least
the two girls are getting invited to
birthday parties all the time
consistently I'm an adventure to say
that both your girls get invited to five
to ten parties a year minimum sure true
story yes all right but that adds up oh
yeah oh yeah that's why I love Amazon
because you can get really cheap gifts
you I and you have some good content on
this on Instagram I know because you
could easily spend you know for these
toys that these kids want thank you 50
bucks easy so I'm like no we're gonna
lower that okay so here's what's
interesting about what they found though
Ken the first study concerns about
fairness responsibility I think tell me
if I'm being naive if you can if if you
had all of your money together as a
married couple like we talk about
there's not technically fairness because
you're seeing it all together right it
doesn't matter who brings in the income
the amount of money that hits our count
is ours that's right and then perceived
responsibility we're all responsible for
all the bills together because we're
we're one so it's actually perceived
irresponsibility and so and if you look
at this so what they're saying is you're
being irresponsible with debt you're
being irresponsible in planning these
were the things that came up that
created conflict
so they were perceiving that their
spouse was irresponsible in the areas of
impulses of course gambling broken
promises and then under fairness I
pointed this one out terms of
Arrangements such as should we combine
finances a lot you know if you look at
another one under fairness
um contributions you know who's paying
these expenses and it's like that all
goes away right if you do what Ramsey
Solutions and what we believe which is
we're all on the same team it's together
your money it's our money yes yes so
pretty interesting I'm a perceived
response why does it say perceived
responsibilities up here or yeah
anyways well are you responsible or
irresponsible so what is what I'm saying
is the findings so not just specifically
about what bills you're responsible for
that's right it's more about are you
responsible or irresponsible in general
as it relates to debt budgeting but
here's the point the reason I point that
out is because a lot of tension there
when one of them this comes back to what
we our basic teaching is we begin to
move people through Financial Peace
University is the nerd or the spender
and so the idea is there can be tension
there because the the nerd the natural
saver yeah thinks that you're being
irresponsible and you go slow your roll
but he's not irresponsible I'm just
trying to live yep yeah 100 100 well
what's interesting too about that is I'm
like even the nerd could actually be the
Spender
and like that's Mom and Dad Dad is the
nerd but he's way the spender my mom is
a little bit more of the free spirit
doesn't care about the budget but she's
the saver so you combine all these this
twisting of everything and it's all
braided together fair in marriage and
having to figure it out so yeah I mean
but this is a big thing you guys because
under all of that is budgeting impulse
spending gambling broken promises
planning debt so all of that for the
most part overarching
can't I hate to say fixed because I know
it's just number quote unquote fix but
it can be this level that Yeah we
actually are way more on the same team
when you communicate you sit down and
you talk about it so all of that it's
just fascinating and then uh yep all of
the mundane expenses which is uh which I
tend to spend more money on so you take
that so that's where I said that's right
but it's it's it's really you nailed it
there I mean that's what the study finds
that's where the tension lies and and so
to the extent that you can go all right
so uh responsibility irresponsibility
what I'm feeling this is a conversation
ago I feel this because this is the way
I'm wired with money know yourself know
your money a fabulous book that you
wrote really does help unpack stuff like
this to know wait a second how I
perceive money may be very different
than how my spouse perceives money but
that's important to understand because
that's where tension arises 100 and
going into those conversations you guys
with this is one thing I feel like I've
just learned over and over it's humility
like I feel like I know what's right and
I feel like I know it's good but what if
I don't know everything and same with
the spouse like if you both come in and
say I I feel like I can learn I want to
learn I want to hear what you have to
say and you both come in like that like
that's a totally different emotional
take than I'm coming in with what I want
what I know is right it's like these
absolutes that I think really get us in
trouble Ken and there's probably in so
many other areas of marriage but
especially with money like if you are
the spender go in with the saver with
your spouse and be like hey what are
they feeling like because maybe they
actually have wisdom going on within
them that I can learn from and then
Savor same thing like go to your spender
and say gosh what are areas of me that
probably need control uh have a level of
scarcity you know like these things that
could be negative on your side what can
you learn from your spouse but that
humility piece I think putting the pride
aside that's really good I wrote down I
wrote down four words just looking at
the study do they all have the same
beginning letter no they don't oh man
but it starts off that way I wrote down
same page same account I think the key
to not having a bunch of big fights
same page that means what do we believe
about debt what do we believe about
saving like are we on the sampling page
gambling right that's right are we on
the same page it doesn't mean that we
agree on everything but it means we're
on the same page Stacy and I realized
this in parenting I know you and Winston
are in the middle of this you're
learning your parenting Styles and as
the kids get older the conflict gets
greater and your Styles come out and
it's
we have learned that and I think this is
true of money
Stacy and I aren't always on the same
line
there's lots of lines on the page yep
but we are on the same page and I think
with money I think it's as complex as
parenting yeah there's a lot of stress
in parenting too and so I think if
you're on the same page we may always
want to be on the exact same line the
same word but we agree this is where we
are on the same page and I think that
allows us to then go okay we do need to
be on the same account I'm still
flabbergasted Rachel by the amount of
couples
that may be on the same page but still
have separate accounts and that creates
all kinds of weirdness all the time I
don't know that you can truly be on the
same page if you have separate accounts
if you're paying for separate bills to
run one household that's just weird to
me yeah it doesn't help you get on the
same page for goals shared goals a
shared future so uh really interesting
stuff Rachel hey we're here to help you
don't move we got to do a few
commercials but we're coming right back
you better be here when we get back this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show helping
you win in your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman Rachel
Cruz joins me to this hour the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five eight eight
two five five two two five Bradley is on
the line in Hattiesburg Mississippi
Bradley how can we help
hey how are y'all doing today we're
having a blast what's going on with you
sir
I had a quick question about
um going to PT school okay
um I was crunching the numbers down and
I was looking of how much it's going to
cost and calling the schools in the
state and out of state is going to run
about 120 Grand
wait you said wait real quick broadly
in-state and out of state because this
should there should be two different
numbers
I looked at some out-of-state programs
and some of the other schools do have a
little bit cheaper programs but those
are kind of far this is like this is the
at like basically what you're saying
120.
yes ma'am to average okay
and I asked about you know what's the
average salary coming out of PT school
and every time about 70 grand to 75
grand
and so I was just kind of wondering you
know it's kind of worth going down that
path if I'm going to possibly take on
that amount of debt I would like to do a
debt free but
look in that amount of money it's going
to be hard to come up with that right
kind of money well this is a tough I get
this question a lot uh and it's tough to
answer because
you get to determine whether or not it's
worth it now it's it's it's not worth it
to go into this kind of debt and and to
to move into that price range to make
that kind of money if you don't have any
kind of growth Beyond 70 75 and that's
that's a that's a long slog and it's
going to be really hard you think it's
hard to come up with 120. it's really
hard to pay it off once it's sitting on
top of you but is it worth it it depends
if that's what you really really want to
do and I think you have to determine
that first and if you determine that
that's what I really really want to do
then you will wait as long as it takes
see I think most people when I if I were
to go on the street with a camera crew
Rachel and say hey are you willing to do
what it takes to to do something you
love and they'd go absolutely and if I
ask the question are you willing to wait
as long as it takes
people kind of go oh how long is that
and I think that's the real tension here
for you and I know it seems like an
insurmountable Hill to climb I'm going
to try to walk you through that it's not
but the question is do you really want
to be into physical therapy or is this
something you're just kind of interested
in and you're kicking the tires so when
I first started my undergraduate degree
this is what I kind of wanted to do at
first
and then they kind of started changing
it up it went from like just a master's
degree to a whole full-fledged doctorate
degree right and so that kind of when
they did that transition that kind of
turned me off a little bit from it but
I've kind of gotten this far I'm about
to finish my Master's Degree here in
December and what
uh Kinesiology okay nice so let me let
me let's pause for a second what
attracts you to being a physical
therapist
go ahead um I've always liked
um human anatomy and physiology
specifically how to improve somebody's
physiology and Anatomy from an injury or
a cardiovascular event anything like
that okay and and what what can you do
with that Masters in kinesiology what
what what fields are open to you that
allows you to do that it may not be
exactly Physical Therapy but you can
still have an impact on someone's
physical health and performance I think
that's what you're drawn to am I right
and I'm trying to summarize that
okay so here's the deal what else can
you do with that Masters in kinesiology
or maybe a little bit more uh
certification process but not the
full-blown 120 000 degree what's
available to you
so in my undergraduate degree I had an
opportunity to work at a cardiovascular
rehab
um clinic in a hospital great and um I
can go that line of work but I was
trying to find jobs online and calling
around and it's not as plentiful as
physical therapy it's okay but let me
throw it to you this way let's say that
I made a phone call today
and I had a job for you in that role
would you take it without looking or
would you go nah I think I'm going to
stay the course and try to do pt
um the role in cardiac rehab yeah
I probably would yes sir all right so
here's my point
it's worth waiting and looking and
knocking on doors connecting to get into
work that allows you to again as I
summarized it help people in their
physical health and performance and not
have to go into debt and not have to
save and wait and wait and wait and wait
for years you're qualified right now to
do what it is you want to do you're just
going to have to shake the tree a little
bit and be patient and be persistent
that's a that's not a fun tension
Bradley how old are you I'm 24. okay oh
yeah so here's here's what I would say
because of how you answered all of Ken's
questions it's not like it was this
dream since I was five years old to go
and be this and now I'm here that's
right it was kind of like oh this is in
general what I enjoy what I'm good at
what I like and so I'm gonna go in this
direction and then it suddenly got
started to funnel down to PT and now
that you're funneling back you're
looking at other options so what I would
say is do what Ken said I would not go
for this I would not go into any more
school that I have to take out debt for
so I would just draw a very hard black
and white black and white line right
there and say okay now what are my
options you know possibly exactly what
you were just describing to can take
some time find that job and then Bradley
honestly when you're 28 years old you
may say and I would love to go to PT
school and your job at that point you'll
be able to save some great cash and
you'll be able to to go back for your
degree I've known lots of people that
have done that so it's this idea that we
have to cram all of our stuff all of our
schooling before we're 24 25 years old
uh I think it's just crazy because you
may not even know what you want to do
and that's not a bad thing but you know
this more general you know practitioner
of what you want to do so go that
direction and then if your passions
start to turn in the next few years then
then yeah what do you do now for a
living and how much do you make
so I'm a gradual assistant so I have my
Master's Degree being paid for right now
oh Austin University it's great and um
so I get a little bit over a grand each
month
um just enough to kind of cover the
lights and food but I mean are you doing
anything in this in this Lane of
physical therapy or something like a
trainer or anything like that
uh not right now so my assistantship is
all research based so okay the professor
I work with we work um in a physiology
lab do Nikki ECGs and putting people on
treadmills and that kind of stuff yeah
you know my both my boys play football
and I will tell you that they've both
been through major injuries and both
surgeries in the last season boy I'm
done with that but I will tell you that
each they go to a great school and
they're the head trainer the athletic
trainer which is working for a local
clinic and then they're assigned to the
school they work hand in glove with
their physical therapist because both
boys are recovering from surgery I'd
look into that space as well and just
see what what does a ladder look like
you know what can you make 50 can you
make 60. I think getting an idea now
while you're in school of what are all
my opportunities that to Rachel's Point
might set me up to the point where I'm
making good money and I'm saving and if
I want to pull the trigger on the PT
later on maybe someone pays for it
because I'm a part of a larger
organization you have to see but I think
what's happened is you have selected
being a PT because it looks like the
most attractive career step with more
jobs available but he answered that
question like if that cardiac therapy
job opened up today he'd take it so so
don't be discouraged because there's not
as many of those jobs but let's also
look at all the different jobs that
would fit that and then hey how about
going after some of those are going
listen here's where I'm at if a job
opens I'm ready I'm Willy and you make
the connections you hustle and I'm going
to give you a book that I wrote called
the proximity principle and it deep
dives into how to turn connections into
opportunities getting around people in
different fields that are all connected
to the type of work you love to do so
hang on the library they want to give
you that as my gift and and what it does
is it's going to demystify how to find
Opportunities yep and Bradley I just
applaud you on even asking the question
because there's a lot of people that we
talk to on this show that are out there
that they PT was always going to be
their next step and regardless of price
tag or not they keep going and then we
talk to them when they're 28 and they're
a hundred and forty thousand dollars in
debt because they haven't been paying
and interest is built to you know what I
mean they're only making ends meet yeah
and so it's just
um you just saved yourself a lot of Life
Bradley I think by even just asking the
question so well done I'm glad you
called I know no one wants to be a
physical therapist and have two side
hustles yes that's what I know and
that's what you're gonna do if you go
into debt for a PT degree and then have
to get in and pay your dues so uh great
question great discipline I believe
there's another path or two or three for
you that would work Bradley so good on
you sir and uh thank you for the call
all right she's Rachel Cruz I'm Ken
Coleman this is the Ramsey show more
coming right up
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show helping
you win in your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman and Rachel
Cruz joins me this hour hey if you're a
new listener or viewer first we want to
say welcome we're thrilled you're here
we're experiencing some tremendous
growth but we also understand that if
you're new to all this language we've
got seven baby steps we talk about
gazelle intensity and all kinds of
things and it's a lot but it's actually
a really simple process and we've got a
website option for you at
ramseysolutions.com and there's a button
there called get started and that will
allow you to kind of Click get in there
figure out where you are in your
financial Journey
as we teach these seven baby steps to
living like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
that's ramseysolutions.com click on get
started and we are here to help again
thank you for joining us New York City
the Big Apple is where we go next
Michael is there Michael how can we help
yes hi how are you oh we're having a
blast what's going on
I need some help in terms of what is my
next step in terms of paying stuff off
or moving forward it's a little bit of
Uncharted water for me and I need a
little bit of help all right lay it out
for Rachel here what's going on show us
the financial picture
hi Financial pitcher I have two hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
uh-oh right everyone's worried we've
heard this before hey Michael you're
you're normal yeah we hear all these
it's awesome
so I hit you with the bad news first uh
but I will tell you if you ask me today
are you uh sorry you did that to
yourself I'm gonna say no
um so I'm an immigration attorney uh
that's uh what a two hundred thousand
dollars uh is for the greatest job I
have I work for myself and I absolutely
love it good for you my my wife has just
graduated uh with our nurse practitioner
license and she works in the operating
room here in New York
um between the two of us we make about
350 000 a year
in terms of debt
we have no debt except for a mortgage of
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars at
this point
in terms of savings right now I'm able
to save about a third of my wife's
salary
uh which goes directly into 401ks which
right now we have about a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
cash right now I have about two hundred
thousand dollars I could pay off
this student loan debt if I wanted to I
don't know if there's a possibility I
know in the past in terms of paying off
debtors you're sometimes able to wheel
and deal throw a one-time payment down
and maybe they take it I just don't know
whether it's beneficial to me and on
that 200 000 I'm making four percent
interest in the bank just kind of
waiting even though my 401k is making 10
or 15 percent
really I'm kind of in a holding pattern
of what to do how to go forward I know
when my if and if in fact I was to die
even though I'm still in my 30s the
student loan debt will die with me it's
not something that my family is going to
have to uh deal with but I'm just a
little bit unsure of where to go from
here in terms of what to pay off how to
move forward it's actually a good
problem to have
um just so looking forward so your
question is do I pay off the house or do
I pay off the loans is that what I'm
hearing right that's the general
question yes yeah well the short answer
is I would pay off the loans first
and is 200k you have saved that's all
that's all the liquid cash you have
right okay because I would take some of
that Michael and keep it
um for an emergency fund I would do you
guys have kids you and your wife I
absolutely three kids three kids okay I
would probably I always Venture more on
the conservative side of just having
just cash in the bank so I would I would
have more like a six-month emergency
fund so you and your wife look at your
budget and say hey expenses wise what
does it take to run our household per
month multiply it by six keep that
amount to the side and then I would
write a check for majority of this money
and go ahead and put it towards your
student loans and then you guys I mean I
would pause 401ks even if it's for two
three months uh I would go through the
hassle doing all that to to pay off the
student loan as quickly as possible
because once that's paid off all that
Consumer Debt is is done and then you
guys can turn right back around be
funding retirement 15 of your income
into a retirement is what we recommend
uh and then I would be looking at your
mortgage which with your income Michael
I mean you guys could be debt free
completely uh so quickly I mean this is
It's really encouraging looking at your
numbers so
um that's that's the progress I would do
and I'm walking you through What's
called the baby steps and it's our seven
step plan that we really go by because
it's the most efficient and effective
way to build wealth we have found
um and and the most
effective way meaning that you're also
going to probably keep your wealth
because within that you're making
decisions in your life and in your money
where you have a really strong uh
Foundation financially with this having
no debt an emergency fund in place but
also you're you're starting to switch
the way you're viewing money you're
starting to switch your habits that will
actually be able to handle the wealth
that you're going to create later
because
um yeah you guys are doing doing
incredible stuff but that's the order I
would do it I would be paying off the
loans as quickly as possible the student
loans and then press play back on
retirement 15 and then be paying off the
house
okay
okay in your opinion do you think that a
student loan provider is at least open
to the idea if ever have you ever heard
is it privately no one negotiating
private no it's it's no it's through the
government yeah I doubt it I doubt it I
hate to say medical usually I feel like
you can negotiate I mean there's there's
different like yeah
it's not illegal for you to take a shot
man ask yeah why not right if I tell
them 130 000 I'll write you a check
right now right and they could you know
right off the records of the 70 to keep
it by emergency fund I love it I put a
little extra New York accent on that too
when you do it I like it I mean a New
Yorker tells me a one-time deal 130 000.
let's do this
you know and even if it doesn't I'd
still I'd still pay off a chunk of this
though Michael if I were you but yeah
yes why not I mean it's the government
so I don't have a lot of Hope in it but
yeah you know the only the only thing
that was really holding me back was like
I said uh it's just something where it's
something that if I passed away suddenly
but you're not in bad Health Michael are
you right so like the stats of you dying
very low it's very low that reasoning is
kind of weird well I shouldn't pay it
off because if I get hit by a bus
tomorrow I mean you don't want to think
about that you know and here's the deal
as Rachel said uh you're totally free of
this I mean this is a massive amount of
money and to to have amassed the amount
of savings that you have to take a huge
chunk out of this and pretty quickly pay
it off really excited for you this is
just a picture of life on the other side
of this
I think that's the visual and Michael I
do Wonder for you because even just
talking to you you're a pretty logical
guy uh but what we have found too
Michael is that money it's not just the
math we look at which we look at that a
lot but there's something physiological
too that happens when you owe someone
money and there's this level of freedom
I think emotionally spiritually that
even your body is going to get out of
this like self-protection mode that it
even is when you owe someone money when
someone has their name on your life that
you have to owe regardless of how people
you know Factor their way out of it
through the math and all the things like
there is still something to be said
about holding that and so for you
Michael I would be so curious with you
and your wife if you guys just go crazy
and you pay this off like the weight
that is lifted that you're carrying that
you may not even realize you're carrying
right
well I'm just curious what is your
homework
a half a million dude
you're gonna you're gonna be debt free
and have a half a million dollar house
paid off that that's what you what
Rachel's talking about what's that gonna
feel like and I think you got to catch
that Vision that she's given to you
there and it's a no-brainer
so you're ready to do it it feels like
you're still chewing on this a little
bit we told you what we would do but
it's your call what are you gonna do
Michael I gotta know what are you gonna
do yeah I'm gonna think about it a
little bit more because I guess what you
told me well wait a second what were you
thinking about doing before you called
us which way were you gonna go I think I
know
can you believe it it's actually neither
it's actually neither you were gonna sit
on the cash
no I'm not going to sit on it um I
really didn't explain the whole story to
you so I worked for someone for six
years as an immigration associate for
someone and in the last year I've went
out on my own and I've really just kind
of blew the roof off of Long Island
immigration okay
um and what I was thinking about doing
is reinvesting it into myself and
reinvesting into a business well I would
say if you pay off those student loans
that is a massive investment in yourself
and remove that weight but I hope you do
that I hope you see that that's the best
play but either way uh excited for you
in your future you'll figure this out
one way or the other I hope you get rid
of that debt it's going to change your
life Rachel Cruz great hour thank you my
friend for hanging out I want to thank
our team Austin and the crew behind the
glass that keep us on the air and we
want to thank you America this is your
show this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help people
you win in your life specifically your
money your work and your relationships
the phone number to jump in is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'm Ken Coleman joined by the gracious
the lovely The Talented Rachel Cruz this
hour
absolutely she is uh fresh off a full
summer three littles it's uh I I bring
this up because you know they're all
getting older now and now they're
getting busy they got activities well
can I tell you my brain feels like it's
in eight different directions okay why I
miss said the baby steps last hour what
if anybody was listening I am fully
aware I skipped baby step one and went
right to baby step three so yeah she was
thinking about that was a dollar
emergency fund before you're completely
debt free including student loans pay
those off and then get a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses I know this can I do but my
mind is going to daughters at a friend's
house Amelia's riding her bike home and
make sure she gets home safe Winston's
taken Charles like no I love what Amelia
is riding her bike home from another
friend's house in the hood isn't that
dream well it's neighborhoods that
connect but that's a step isn't that oh
yeah now we you and I grew up doing that
I know and it feels so good because I
want her I'm like I want you to live the
childhood that you all deserve so we got
her an Apple Air tag and so you know
where she's like a little bracelet so we
can track her and she knows what time to
ride home yes and I have the parents
number too so we're right they're like
she's leaving and I'm like thank you
eight minutes she has eight minutes
eight minutes big deal when you see her
rolling in the house and she feels so
big big girl that's exciting fun stuff
in a good neighborhood for bike riding
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah highly recommend
it if you can get into a neighborhood
where your kids have some freedom and
it's safe let them go back in the day
and boy I'm old now we we would
disappear at this is Summer Morning we'd
leave at 8 8 30 in the morning yes and
wouldn't come back until 5 30 6 o'clock
and my parents had no earthly idea where
I was I know okay I know this is nothing
she has nothing to do with the show real
quick though I think we can tie it
what's your we'll find a way to talk
about money in this yeah but do you
think can with your older age than me is
it truly that we it's become more
dangerous do you think because it the
world does feel more dangerous or do you
think it's because we're so used to
having a handle on everything all the
time because of Technology oh I love
this which is it this is a hot take
right here uh I don't believe the world
is more dangerous I believe that creeps
and evil was around when you and I were
kids I just think we're more aware and
we I feel afraid we feel more danger
than there is there's no more danger
than there was we just feel it and we're
aware we're scared and uh that example
that I use is a classic example my mom
and dad obviously were responsible
parents but it was one of those
situations where they're like okay are
you going to be in our neighborhood or
your grandparents neighborhood and you
got to check in with us or your
grandparents at noon for lunch and you
checked in and so if we didn't check in
there would have been an issue sure but
there also wasn't by the way I didn't
use elbow pads knee pads or a bike
helmet uh and I always get hot you know
hot water for saying that but we've
gotten so safety conscious that what it
has done is elevated our fear and great
marketers scare us and the news people
God bless them we have friends in the
news industry sure they would tell you
this if it bleeds it leads is the old
phrase and and so when you are scared in
order to pay attention and you are
scared in order
on on the other side of the country and
immediately because of social media like
you get you get news and everything so
quickly and so here's the point we're
more aware of all of the danger I think
we were just blissfully unaware the fact
that it was like yeah
I probably just rode my bike by some Ax
Murderer but for whatever reason he
didn't get out of the car you know but
like now it's like you're afraid to let
your kid be out of your site in a
department store let me tell you
something I can't tell you how many
times
um I got lost in a department store and
showed up crying at one of the registers
with the parents of Kenny Coleman please
report to the men's area it happened all
the time yeah you never never happened
today we put leashes on kids
a kid walking around like a Labrador
Retriever hey there are some kids that
are Runners and if you're a mom you're
tired I never put my kids on a leash but
I do see them sometimes right now I'm
really gonna offend some people if you
let me tell you why I didn't need a
leash my dad would have whipped mine but
if I had to run from here in the mall
you want to be a runner all right I'll
teach you a lesson
three it's a
convenient for the mom of like I'll tell
you what you can't run off I don't like
the leash I tell you what I do like I
like the little cute preschool thing
where they all they grab their little
Loop then they grab the Rope that's kind
of cool and stuff you got three kids buy
a rope they all gotta grab the little
one hold on I'm up for this week there's
still some free will involved in that
see that's why I like that yeah yeah
they have a choice to let go I digress
but I do think this here's what we're
going to tie it all in
no this is good radio I don't care who
you are uh
fear drives us to make poor decisions
with our money
we get credit cards as a backup plan
because what if what if what if and
you've got a lot of money out of the
market because we get nervous yep
there's it so fear does play in our
money our work and our relationships and
we have to have a healthy relationship
with fear but we got to dive into fear
enough to at least be able to say is
there something here so there you go
there's where we tie it all in it's
great Ken so there we go fear will will
motivate you yeah don't make decisions
based on fear let's go to Salt Lake City
Utah Greg is joining us there Greg how
can we help
hey Ken hey Rachel how are you guys
doing good how are you sir
I'm good um so my question is I'm on a
baby step two I've been working the plan
for maybe about four months now uh went
through Financial Peace University and
I'm almost done with all my debts
besides my last one the death snowball
really does work
um and now I'm just wondering my last
bet is my car if I should sell it or not
I really think I should sell it but also
I don't know give us the numbers real
quick we got about a minute and a half
give us the uh the debt on it and how
much it's worth
um so I owe 32k on it and it's about 35
and I think Rachel I think you have a
Tesla it is a Tesla I love the things
that makes sense
I don't know uh what do you make a year
Greg
um so right now I've been gazelle
intense with paying off my 20K of credit
cards
I have three jobs um but I make like 70k
with having those three jobs but if it
was just to have be my full-time job
it'd be around like 45. okay so 70k okay
so basically we kind of our rule of
thumb Greg just so you know the math
where we always say if you can pay it
off within a year to 18 months then you
can keep it but here's the deal you pay
it off in 18. okay so here's the deal
though Greg do you want to live that
life what you're talking about two side
hustle all of this to keep the car or do
you sell it be completely debt free get
kind of a not not I mean after you've
been driving the Tesla it's hard it is
hard but go step back you know
I know I know I'm just kidding but go
get a used car yeah go get a used car
and then save up the cash and buy one
later just to be debt free like is it
worth doing all of this for the Tesla as
the question would you do this to buy a
Tesla would you live would you live the
two side Hustle Life for it
I don't mind the two side hustle because
you know okay well if you can pay it off
in 18 months Greg where we give you the
green line that's great just keep
working those side hustles pay off the
car or if you're just like man I'm
exhausted I want to be out of debt sell
it be completely debt free and then
drive something else and save up money
and get you the car again if you want in
the future so up to you either way love
it thanks for the call Greg all right
Rachel's got to go plug her car in while
we do some commercials we'll be right
back this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
Hollow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling hallow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five eight
eight two five five two two five Kate is
on the line in Boise Idaho Kate how can
we help
Hi how are you guys we are having a
blast what's going on Kate
okay
my question is
um should me and my husband basically
off our solar panels on our house before
we pay off any of the rest of our debt
um just to give you guys a little bit of
backstory my husband is making about 70
to 80 000 a year I'm in my second year
of Law School
so I don't have a regular income I have
a couple five gigs that bring in a
little bit of extra money
the question comes from his
he
bought a home with his ex-girlfriend
um in 2021 she ended up leaving him and
his parents ended up having to purchase
the home to get her off of the the
mortgage
um I don't know why they didn't
necessarily
lump the
um Fuller payment into the the sale of
the house but now she is calling us
relentlessly and harassing us and
degrading him saying that you know he's
not a man for not being able to
get her name off of this solar panic
so wow
yeah yeah we all went to high school
together so it's a fun time that's even
more exciting so great all right
okay Kate what is he how much is left on
the solar panels
so those solar panels are it's still
forty thousand dollars it's at a 2.99
interest rate for 25 years okay and what
we had
what other dead do you guys have
so we're in about 95 000 of debt besides
that we have a
truck payment that she actually got
repoed
um that was in his name we have a
trailer how much how much is a railroad
okay okay keep going sorry
um he works for the railroad so he we
have a trailer that he stays in and that
actually brings in a little bit more of
the income
um another truck payment and then my
student loans okay how much are your
student loans
currently right now they're 30 000
um I still have two years to finance and
so we were trying to pay this off ASAP
to start how much are the two how much
you guys owe in the two trucks
two trucks are combined 26 000.
um like I said one of them we don't even
own anymore because it was repoed when
they were together okay
and then how much is the trailer
the trailer is about thirty thousand
okay and how are you making income on
that you said
so the way that it works as far as his
work is he gets like um
kind of like a hotel
to Doom I guess okay
um it's essentially
140 I believe a day
um that he's at work he gets it for a
hotel but since he's not staying in a
hotel basically he Pockets that and then
we've been making payments on the
trailer how much is the payment per
month on the trailer
the trailer is 310.
310 okay and how many days is he staying
in the in the trailer and getting the
stipend
um so he works eight days on six days
off it's kind of a rough estimate
because sometimes he does work more days
never less oh okay
oh man
um
and she wants you guys she wants to be
off the solar panel loan
because
um obviously you guys aren't they're not
using it but they both agreed to get the
solar panel on this home correct
correct it was not against her will she
she willingly put her name on that loan
correct he didn't go behind her back or
like no do anything like that yeah and
and you're paying it on are you behind
on that payment on that bill
no we're we're current on it I can only
assume because she got remarried about
six months after she left him
um so I'm just assuming that maybe she's
trying to purchase a new home with her
husband or I don't have any idea okay
um well I if I were him I would want her
of it too not have this like attached
loan right together because it doesn't
sound like a very amicable
um relationship but also it's unfair for
him to take the well I guess but the
solar panels are with the home well the
home is now if I'm understanding this
right the home is owned by his mom and
dad own the home
yeah so when they purchased the home she
put a little bit of her own savings into
it so that was another thing that she
harassed them about and they he ended up
agreeing to sell the home to his parents
um because the market went up a little
bit so he ended up cutting her a check
for what she put in her savings and a
little extra right but that's fine what
we're trying to do is figure out what
you can do here and so the parents own
the home that the solar panels panels
are on correct correct
yeah I guess I'm with Rachel I
she's not go you're never gonna get a
nickel from her on those anyway so I'd
get her off of it just so you don't have
to deal with her anymore I would never
want to talk to this woman again and
then but the home is being benefited by
the solar panels so do his parents I
mean if I was a parent I'd go that's not
my problem I already bailed you out once
right but she you know I know but what
she's saying is though like because
because usually is it right Kate that
the solar panels you just kind of like
lump it in with the mortgage because
it's using to run the household is is
that what is happening
I don't know so it's a separate loan
loan not with the house yeah this is
already a mess and you need to remove
yourself from this woman there needs to
be massive boundaries so
um Rachel unless I'm missing something
yeah to the extent that you can contact
the solar panel folks and take her name
off the loan I would do it
if that's what your question was well
our issue is is I've I don't have a job
um a lot of when they go and pull his
credit a lot of it is the fact that they
have that vehicle that was repoed and
then on top of it our debt to income
looks so substantially High because
we're still trying to clean up the mess
that
they basically created yeah and yes okay
well then don't do it then I mean you're
paying on it right
yeah yeah yeah I know we make the
payments every month we pay the mortgage
every month we basically just transfer
over the money to his parents I mean you
know what honestly Kate if I were you
guys you guys need just some breathing
room as I'm looking at your numbers I'm
like yeah way more than half of your
annual income is is you know trucks and
trailers there's a part of me that I'm
like get rid of the 30 000 trailer go
stay in the hotel take the Stipe and
they're paying for it anyways that'll
give you thirty thousand dollars a
breathing room I would look at the
triple the one trucks repoed but you
know what what is the other truck that
you actually own what is it what's it
worth and how much debt is on that
um so that one's thirteen thousand I
don't know what is what the value of it
is but it is his work truck he's a
mechanic for for the railroad so that's
what he drives around you know so let me
just tell you right now okay since he's
a mechanic
uh I can't do any of this stuff that I'm
about to tell you but I if that car
let's say that truck's worth 15. I'd
sell it and then go get a beater or
something like that because he can fix
it and we're just trying to get out of
it just trying to like get some
breathing room okay y'all have it is a
lot you said there's a lot of ratio from
income to debt and you're exactly right
so if I were you guys you're caring so
much of this weight around I would want
to start dropping some weights where I
could that made sense but some of these
you can't drop you can't drop the thirty
thousand dollar suit alone the dang
solar panels are there but you can drop
a trailer you can drop a truck like you
guys need to start making progress with
your money to at least get your head
above water and Kate I'm gonna say this
too because I feel like in good
conscience I can't get you off the phone
before I do two more two more years of
law school and not being able to pay for
you guys are going deeper into it the
whole you're in you guys keep digging
out the bottom and so I would really
kind of prioritize and look at where
where are we at what are our goals
um I mean I I know that's a lot we just
put on you but they're they're I would
make some drastic moves Kate I would
because it's just stuff you know what
it's just stuff to that end this is
crazy but I would ask somebody uh what
if I go over to the in-laws house so we
take them solar panels off the top of
the house and three sounds I Trek into
it Somebody's gotta know that Somebody's
gotta know I would try it I mean try to
sell them if you can wow wow I need to
look that up this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz a
shower we're here for you helping you
win with your money your work and your
relationships the phone number to jump
in if you'd like to is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
Triple Eight
825-5225 okay so I want to give you all
some some updates on on where we're at
in our economy right now new jobs report
uh information out but then overall
economic report and and this matters
because you see so many headlines you
see uh so many things in the news and
are we in a recession will we go into
one all this kind of stuff but but let
me just tell you where we're at a couple
things as it relates to inflation okay
new inflation numbers in inflation was
at three percent in July that's year
over year and that is a drop if you'll
remember back to last June Rachel it was
at 9.1 okay
and uh so core inflation
um is at 4.8 percent that is the lowest
since October 2021 so we'll it'll be
interesting to see if you begin to see
that uh in your pocketbook okay and now
some other good news as it relates to
your income
uh wage growth is significantly above
inflation for the first time since March
2021 wages are up 4.4 percent
and inflation is up three percent in the
past year so we look back at the last 12
months year over year uh so it'll be
interesting to see do we stay in this
continued hot job market because we are
in a good job market so we'll see how
that relates to groceries and gas but
where is inflation right now the very
interesting list by the way I'm sourcing
Heather long who is the economy reporter
for the Washington Post and this is not
her opinion this is data
from the latest report so in the past
year so where are we feeling inflation
As Americans rent up
8.3 in the past year eating out as far
as eating out costs 7.7 eating out can
we just sit on that people get so mad at
us when we're like eat in it's cheaper
well they just they lose their minds
7.7 increases housing in general takes
up a big bulk of the inflation number in
general so that being up at 3.3 is Big
yep eating out this next line is one you
don't think about enough until you get
to the old emergency fund and people
driving older cars you know versus do I
drive a Ramsay car if you will versus a
brand new car well car maintenance the
cost of your maintaining your car up
12.7 car insurance this is crazy
plus 16.9 percent yes up almost 17 from
last year the insurance rates up now
where has inflation eased at the gas
pump range
negative 26 and a half percent used cars
this is a good sign by the way because
used cars were really hot now we've seen
a dip in used car prices drop negative
5.2 percent uh this is barely
registering but meat has dropped just
two tenths of a point and if you have
two teenage boys like I do doesn't
matter let me tell you where we felt it
and no joke the amount of tacos
hamburger meat oh yeah and bacon that I
buy
I mean it's unbelievable so much yeah
wait till Charles becomes a teenage boy
you're gonna think he's got a tapeworm
yeah you just keep eating and eating and
eating it's fantastic I don't know where
it goes and then this is exciting for
Rachel I know she declared this was the
year of travel as I recall I thought we
had an event last fall you're like I'm
excited about traveling well it looks
like airfare has dropped according to
this uh airfares have dropped 18.9 so
and that is great we were looking at
some stuff for uh the fall and yeah and
like there was like a yeah one way was
like 200 bucks with America I mean it's
back to like reason what I feel like
yeah was reasonable really good range
for the most part so really good rates
that's where we're at thanks Ken The
Economist yeah well no just a man of the
people trying to appreciate that so
here's the good news yeah it's down we
can celebrate that because we talked
about how much inflation is up y'all I
mean it's it's down to three three
percent that's good for the household
budget now here's the deal okay go wage
increases are up still so here's the
deal you can still still make more money
but please don't spend it save it yes
put it towards the baby steps put it
towards the baby step two if you're in
the middle of that hey I am working the
debt snowball I get to that emergency
fund baby step three if you're in 3B or
you're trying to save for the first
here's the point get it while the
getting is good wages and Jobs still
good but we are seeing starting to see
some inflation yeah drop that's a great
point for the household budget expenses
because Winston and I we use every
dollar which is our budgeting tool you
guys if you have not done every dollar
make sure to get this we've had it out
since 2015 and it helps you get
organized save money and build the life
that that you really want uh it's really
helped us in so many ways and so it's
great because I can go back and look at
last year's monthly you know uh budget
and to be like okay realistically where
were we at and it will help you say okay
where can I cut stuff because things
have lowered here lowered their up to
you know like everything that list you
just read out Ken but it helps you
really plan it so I'm gonna just say it
again because it is my favorite and I
was looking at it even during the break
but every dollar uh our budgeting up
it's incredible and the Premium plan you
guys is the thing that I would get
because it actually connects to your
bank you can do paycheck planning goal
setting budget reports there's Financial
coaching even in there group coaching
like there's so much in this every
dollar premium and for right now we're
actually giving you 15 off your first
year of the premium version of every
dollar and so that's gonna be
64.99 for the first year
Versa being about eighty dollars so uh
go to everydollar.com Rachel and please
say every dollar or the um to type that
in but put in Rachel again
everydollar.com Rachel and make sure you
get 15 off because
um that premium version of every dollar
that connects to your bank again it
allows you to do so much when it comes
to paycheck planning and Road mapping
but you guys like this is the stuff like
when we talk about that inflation's back
down to three percent like Ken said that
is money in your pocket and if you've
gotten a raise and if you know you're
you're seeing that wage increase use
that margin you guys and be intentional
with that budget it know what's going on
because it's so easy on all Scapes
depending on you know what's going on in
the economy
um just to completely lose that and the
lifestyle increase is real that budget
creep that lifestyle creep is real if
you're not watching your number so be
diligent in this you guys I mean the
intentionality that Winston and I do for
our budget we're we're consistent with
it it's because I'm like you work hard
for your money right I'm like you're
going to work you're you know for some
of you guys you're traveling you're
commuting
um you're dealing with people at work
you don't like I mean like there's just
so much that goes into working and if
you make that paycheck let it let it go
far and being intentional and having
your numbers in a budget with every
dollar premium it's it's a thing that's
going to help you yeah and so you know I
want to stay here for a minute because
here's what I want people to understand
we have a lot of new people Rachel as
you know joining us all the time if you
if you live
financially the way that we teach here
you are Recession Proof you are
inflation-proof now I don't want that to
sound overly simplistic so let me
qualify that that doesn't mean that
inflation doesn't suck and you won't
feel it the difference is it won't break
you and so here's what we know when a
recession comes and goes and depending
on the economy and what that means
because sometimes you can go through a
recession it doesn't affect your job at
all sometimes you get laid off
when you have Financial Peace and you
understand the process of how to budget
you talk about every dollar you can
adjust things on the Fly because you
have control and I think that's the
thing I want to point out because if you
look at rent rent is still very high yep
so you've got some people going wait a
second in this economy it's it's so well
I can adjust in other areas of my life
that's right if I'm having to rent
because I'm not able to buy where else
am I going to cut because I have control
over a lot of my expenditures to be able
to weather these storms you know you
hope to see rents drop rent has been on
a steady increase I just was looking at
the details while inflation is down in
June 70 percent of the three percent
inflation was solely
dedicated to rent costs going up yes so
you're right and so that's hurting
people yeah we're talking about shelter
that's right that's right so I wanted
you to speak to that briefly just
encourage them 30 seconds here on how
they could control those four walls and
the rest of their spending to go hey I'm
gonna have to buckle down to make it
through this storm oh yeah for sure I
mean it is the food shelter utilities
and transportation it's the things that
you have to have and the hard thing is
is I'm like to make sacrifices on those
it's not fun it's not fun to be like oh
my gosh we can't eat exactly what we
could we wouldn't go to the grocery
store and buy everything we may not be
able to rent in the place we want to
rent or the type of you know location we
want to rent maybe we have to drive
further out but getting those under
control and that's going to give you a
level of Peace because those are the
things that you're worried about it's
like do I have a roof over my head do I
have food that we can eat so when people
when your budget is really tight on that
make sure that those things are covered
first all right there you go good stuff
don't move more of your calls coming up
she's Rachel Cruz I'm Ken Coleman this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague Rachel
Cruz the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to Genie who joins us in
Miami Florida Genie how can we help
hi hi Rachel hi Ken thank you for taking
my call sure I just wanted to start with
my question is should I stay in a toxic
work environment for a pension and full
medical benefits I have seven years and
seven months left before I can retire no
now I want to dive in and I want to help
you but the simple answer is no
because what is probably happening and
you can tell me but I'm going to guess
that
that what is probably happening is
having a mental emotional and physical
impact on your body and gritting that
out for seven more years is not good for
your health
and so I would never tell someone to do
something that's not healthy for them so
that's where I start so what's going on
what's the toxicity and how's it
affecting you a back story
um instead of complaining about
management my husband and I are both in
the same line of work I decided to take
the supervisor's test and nine days
before I was completing my probationary
period I was told that I don't need
expectations however I am allowed to
sign up for the next supervisor test
which my husband has also decided to do
um so when in doing in on my
probationary period I was doing great up
until a specific evaluator and again by
State Statute I'm not allowed to contest
the probationary period however I don't
mind you know taking it again
um I have already since this has
happened an incident happened at work
that I had the contact HR to file a
complaint and I'm just a little bit
worried about I mean a no retribution
and everything but um
it's I just I loved my job what I was
doing and I think if
um God allowed me to go back into it I
could work through it because I didn't
matter the politics and everything at
work I I loved what I was doing is this
the same company
yes
okay so I'm confused
um you you were in a job that you loved
and you applied to be a supervisor and
you haven't gotten it so what job are
you I was able to I was on a probation
period so you're allowed to be a
supervisor for a year oh I see so you're
in it but you're on a but you're in a
situation where it's toxic and you
haven't told me what's toxic about it
well what is so toxic
basically uh the supervisor that um
started my last four or five evaluations
is was just very
um condescending and that just is the
way he is just his nature his
personality I went along to get along
because unfortunately I do work it's a
it's a police department so
um you know it's a male dominated
environment I went along to get along
his behavior has never been you know
um corrected or anything like that and
um so let me ask you this if can you put
up with him long enough to see if it's
going to be a possibility for you to go
back to your previous role
yeah he wouldn't he wouldn't have to be
my supervisor like because of the
complaint I already just filed I don't
know if he's even allowed to technically
be my supervisor now
um I don't know but here's what I'm
asking so the way you pose the question
is should I leave a toxic situation uh
and I said no I mean I mean should I
stay in a toxic situation I said no but
I'm not sure that this is toxic now
after talking to you and I'm not in any
way trying to belittle or or disagree
with you but it feels like to me that
this is something that you love the
previous role of being a police officer
you don't like the supervisor part of it
and there's a possibility that you can
go back to just being a police officer
and I'm saying can you stay in the
supervisory role long enough to
determine whether or not they'll say you
know what we get it Genie you don't like
it you want to go back I'm asking can
you stay in there long enough because
that's going to change my answer
potentially as to whether you stay or go
so what is the answer
no uh so I'm confused about the question
I guess okay you're in a supervisor role
right now you don't like no I'm no
longer they removed it from me nine
years nine days before my okay my
professional series so I'm confused
you're back in the position that you
used to love yes or no no I'm I'm in a I
was a police officer and instead of
complaining about management I decided
to
um stop complaining and put in for the
man a supervisor position like take a
test so I took a test and I made the
list and I was made back
um last year
okay but you're not happy where you are
bottom line correct yeah then leave
here's the deal you have two options I'm
a little confused and I don't want to
keep confusing the audience because if
I'm confused they're confused but so
here's the deal you have two options you
either stay where you are in a role that
you don't enjoy we're clear on that
until you can get clear from your
leaders that you could go back to the
other role
and if you can't then you need to leave
because it's not worth seven years of
being unhappy that's that I'm clear on
does that make sense does that answer
your question because you can you
financially we can help you win but
Genie does it help that because you
filed this complaints recently that he
may not be is he your talk is he the
toxic part of the job is that is he the
only part because if he's not your if
you if you're not have to report to him
does that help the situation where
you're at yeah okay and do you think
that's gonna happen
no I won't I I there's so many
supervisors that I won't need to be I
can easily never have to work with him
okay so does that does that solve your
problem like could you stay and you're
never gonna have to report to him so
does that is it still talking yeah I
could say and then take the test again
and try to pass and then redo the
probationary period yes that that will
that and then I mean and again I know
that wouldn't I wouldn't see that person
again so that would be great yeah I
could stay there and do the job to
continue to do the job that I loved okay
well so then there it is if he's the
only toxicity in this entire situation
and it's removed then then stay but but
again back to my answer if you get to a
point where you're not happy there
and you don't want to go in every day
don't do that for seven years yeah and
you don't say for yes the pension the
health care for seven years yeah because
you can go get good health care and the
pension we can put you with us with a
smart investor Pro can help you
transition all that you never though
here's the bigger because we get this
question well it's a very good question
by the way by Genie yep yep okay never
stay in a situation at work that you are
very unhappy with just because you have
good benefits because the the
detrimental effect on your mind your
soul and your body mental emotional
physical
is very clear yeah you'll wreck your
body yep there's all kinds of it affects
your immune system I mean nerd out here
for a second but when you are when you
are unhappy at work and you were
unfulfilled and all of the stress and
the longing that comes with that it
begins to build up into what they call
burnout which is an actual symptom but
that has the effect of immune system
being lowered your energy is lower you
can pull on weight I mean it goes on and
on and on that doesn't even count for
the maybe anxiety right depression right
so yeah I don't want to make this like
this beautiful thing yeah you were a
whole person that's right that's right
so your work your parenting right your
mayor everything it is all one you guys
and so there's not just one part of your
life that you're like well I'll come
over here and be in a terrible
environment for eight hours a day and
everything else in my life is gonna be
okay it's not it's gonna affect every
part of your life so as much of a
holistic picture that you can get of
Health all the way around with your
money with your relationships with your
work everything you just enjoy life more
you guys and so um and I know that's
easier said than done because people are
in really tough situations and changing
jobs is really difficult it's scary I
mean there's a lot of logistics there we
understand that but for the betterment
of you
um that's worth it and what Ken saying
is is exactly right and to your point
we're also saying don't jump don't just
jump on the right plan come up with
another job and so we move we take care
of us but there's no risk here and I
think it feels risky but what we would
teach you is unless you're in an abusive
danger like your life is in danger
there's something really creepy going on
to where it's like leave today yeah yeah
sure and let's just okay let's find
another boat to get on and we step onto
that boat and we move on with our life
so financially we're not putting
ourselves at risk by taking care of our
mental physical and emotional health
related to work so Jeannie I'm glad that
the situation is better hang in there
you're going to be great thank you for
serving the people of Miami putting
yourself in danger mad respect for our
officers of the law and officers of
peace they put themselves on the front
line every day so thank you for that
Rachel Cruz great hour I want to thank
Austin the entire team keeping us on the
air behind the glass and to you America
thank you for listening and watching
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we help you win in
your life specifically with your money
your work and your relationships the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Rachel Cruz is my co-host I am Ken
Coleman and we are thrilled to be with
you take your questions about your money
and uh and work related and income
issues
today as Rachel and I sit in together
thrilled to have you with us John is up
in Dallas Texas John how can we help
okay
hello John
hi uh thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it you bet
okay so I'm a band teacher in a public
school I'm single I'm debt free I have
four months of my income in emergency
funds and uh I'm pretty much in control
of my budget uh the part where the
reason for my calls is that 40 of my
income right now is going towards my
mortgage
and uh the way I had tried to justify
that the 15 of that was oh I'll just cut
back on these ratios of my budget
um to fit that you know that payment and
so I've been fine I still have about 13
left over miscellaneous after uh putting
in for retirement and savings but I'm
really in calling to find out you know
I'm lying to myself about what situation
I'm in or if I'm truly okay and and last
little last little thing is I really
just found you guys two weeks ago
through the uh the happy hour that you
guys have oh yeah and just started
following just start following your
stuff um intently the last two weeks so
it kind of put me in a guilty place of
uh thinking if that makes sense yeah
well you've done it a fantastic job up
until that point John without following
it's like we're the only some of the
only voices out there that are like be
debt free have an emergency fund all
that and you've done it all just on your
own which is very impressive
um so yeah so the 40 uh it is High I
mean we really do say 25 if you push it
to 30 you could but that 25 marker is
kind of where we usually land because
um
because we want you to be able to have
margin with your money and with your
income to do other things but the fact
that yeah where you are life's um
seasonal life-wise being single no kids
like all of it like you could you could
get away with it if you wanted to but I
just think John you would have more of
an enjoyable discretionary life and
income and stuff with it not eating up
more than you know close to half your
income is that take home pay by the way
yeah that'll take home pay okay and
where tell me about your living
situation are you living close to the
school are you house are you apartment
are you a condo like where are you at so
I live so right so I live in a house
um where I got my mortgage and uh I'm
basically about 30 minutes away from the
school that I teach at okay I teach in a
suburb away from my
um school just because I couldn't even
afford a house by my school yeah and um
and so really the reason why I got into
the house was I was like okay it was a
new bill so I was gonna go into a
bidding war with people at the time and
interest rates and
um but you know like you said I felt
guilty about that 15 of like what you
know being debt free I'm like I'm kind
of like Sharon I feel better about
myself at this point being debt free
like that's kind of what made me yeah
really start to question that 15 that
was going out to my mortgage even though
the area that I live in you guys just
talked about earlier you know it's about
30 of my income just in rent around
Graham anyways right so that's why I'm
kind of like well at least I'm investing
15 and something that's appreciating
sure so so again I don't know if that's
just me lying to myself again or if
that's just you know well I think you
answered yeah you answered it in a way
though John because you you said I feel
like I should feel better being tempt
free than at this point and I mean for
you math wise how much would 15 back in
your pocket be for you do you do you
know that math about it's about six six
to seven hundred dollars okay you know
are you single John yeah
I am yeah
yeah look one option for the short term
and I I don't know I'm not getting in
your relational business I but would you
be willing to get in a roommate or two
well it's funny I had someone else and
their their reply Let's Get Married
um and so yeah well yeah except for the
fact we got to find the right person and
make sure it's the one for the rest of
our lives yeah are you dating anyone
like is there someone
at some point I would like to do that
but you know there's a little bit more
to it than just meth
um but uh yeah I mean I've considered a
roommate
um and to be honest with you being a
band teacher I mean I can I can
definitely
the way I thought about it was I can
give lessons here and make up for that
area of my budget to compensate and so I
don't know if that's something that's
also like an option yeah yeah because I
mean the way to fix the 40 is up the
income or move yeah or find somewhere
different but do you wanna is it worth
working extra for you to stay in the
house that that would just be the
question
yeah that's that's the question that I
honestly kind of go back and forth in
yeah it's kind of that time versus when
it's gonna help you know I do like
living in a house and and this current
market that we're in to be honest with
you as a teacher it's very hard to even
get a house
so what do you owe on the house
um it's 230 uh original was 250 000. and
what's owed now is 230. so here's my
question if you're willing to have a
roommate or two for a season maybe it's
a year or two I'd say a year goes by
fast you know two I'm just asking you to
consider I'm not you know you have to
comment here but but all of a sudden if
you were able to take that rent that you
were to get for someone and put that
towards the principle you have no other
debt you could knock that principal down
and now you put yourself in a really
good situation do you know what I'm
saying so you're reducing your expenses
so you've got more margin if you want to
start getting lessons on top of that I
just think I would consider that giving
the fact that rent is going to be really
high where you are and you're already in
and you're single because he's single
Rachel yeah I kind of want him to hang
on to this thing and find and find
another way to reduce expenses do you
see your regular
um income as a band teacher going up
John like what's the what's the
percentage for teachers like what's the
race I mean to be quite honest with you
I think for any teacher
they would love to tell us that our
raises go up every year but really what
it does is our raises go up with
inflation yeah yeah yeah yeah it's not
them yeah so in other words it sounds
like it's going up in salary but is this
really going up with inflation but you
got your Summers brother what are you
doing this summer
uh my summer has literally been I'm so
I'm a pretty Frugal person and uh my
summers are really just
staying home cooking and just enjoying
not uh commuting to be honest with you
well if you want to say I think Rachel
asked the right question do you are you
willing to get a roommate are you
willing to work during the summer bring
in some extra income all to keep the
house and and that's your decision I
don't get a say in that neither does she
but I will tell you if I was playing the
role of your older brother I'd say keep
the house but change your income
situation or reduce your expenses
because you're in yeah and even do the
math John for next summer and say gosh
what if I did private lessons next
summer from 10 to 3 P.M every hour I
mean for three months that's a lot of
cash too so and a roommate for a season
for a year knocks that principal down
big time yeah so yeah I would say John
if you had a ton of debts no savings I'd
get out of that house ASAP but you're
not in that situation so there's some
more time to get some options and to get
that income up
thanks for the call John don't move more
the Ramsey show coming up
[Music]
foreign
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz this
hour and we're taking your calls about
your money your work and your
relationships triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five Abby
joins us from our nation's capital Abby
how can we help
hi hi
hello I'm so excited to talk to you guys
well we're excited to talk to you yeah
what's going on
uh first cat I'd have to say I took your
get clear assessment recently when it
was recommended by my therapist and it
gave me so much Clarity
um like with my career and it described
me perfectly it was wonderful well
that's so great well thanks for sharing
that glad you're glad you're on your way
so how can we help you today
yeah so um as of Saturday I will be desk
for you finally
congratulations nice thank you thank you
I put in my application for my debt-free
screen so see if I get down there that
I'm on the show that day that'll be fun
that would be awesome all right yeah so
um I'm getting ready to
region is kind of two-fold um the first
part is I know it's three to six months
of expenses and that's kind of a wide
range so I was hoping you guys could
help me nail down like if you think
based on my situation I can do more
three or four or whatever and then
um the second part is like when you're
talking about the daily expense or the
monthly expenses sorry
um when I'm looking at my budget like
what budget line should I be looking at
in order to create that number yeah it's
a great question so for the first one
are you are you single married kids
I'm single single okay and what kind of
job do you have
I work for a school I'm a program
specialist at an elementary school okay
great
um yeah so in that case you know I you
could lean more three months Abby I mean
I always when there's more things
happening AKA kids or if there's a job
that maybe if you were you know if you
were doing freelance and you know your
income was very commission based like
anything that has a ton of variables is
where I start to lean more to the six
month side of the three to six months
range but where you are single
um very steady job consistent income you
know it's coming in you're able to plan
uh I mean I would be comfortable yeah
with you more in the three three month
range for sure
okay that's what I was thinking too I
just wanted to make yes and I would say
too I mean whatever feels good to you
because for some people they're like
nope I really want that like five months
or I just want to have that number
because it feels great like whatever
makes you sleep at night and feel better
okay do that but from a mathematical
life standpoint you could totally do the
three month and be great and then the
other question you had yeah we get this
one too a lot because it and this one
ranges for people Everyone kind of has a
different opinion on it depending on
honestly probably your personality so
like for Winston and I I just took our
standard operating budget for what we
spend which included some luxury things
right so subscriptions and it includes
us out going out to eat it includes our
date nights it includes um kids sports
like it's it's basically our life
basically month to month and we use that
number and did basically six months of
that some other people said no I'm gonna
do a Bare Bones budget that if something
really happened and I lost a job I
didn't get income I could cut a bunch of
stuff and still be okay with my four
walls and maybe a few other things so
their number was smaller so it's what
again wherever you're comfortable at
that number
um is where you would go so I I like to
think of if crap hit the fan and
something happened I still want to keep
my life as consistent as possible if I
can I mean obviously naturally you would
probably pull back anyways sure but I
just like to use that number for yeah
for the Math's sake
um but for some people Abby yeah they're
like oh no I don't I we would cut out we
would cut everything which you may do
anyways but and and get a very a smaller
number
um for that to be your emergency fine
yeah does that help I wasn't yeah I
wasn't sure if it was like
um selfish of me to include like my
entertainment budget and my gym
membership like I wasn't sure if that
was like oh you shouldn't include that
stuff in what you would consider monthly
expenses but I like what you said with
like you would want your life to be as
consistent totally as possible and again
the truth is if something really bad
happened you probably would cut some of
that just as a person of you know just
as a human being to be like I will cut
back naturally but I just like having
that bigger number
just because it's just that extra
question I don't know yep yeah and I
rent right now so I don't like I don't
have any like something the hot water
heater is going to go or something like
that it's really just my car and if I
was gonna lose my job like how would I
pay yes but I'm not losing my job
anytime soon yeah yeah I think that's
great for you good job Abby well done
well done thank you so much for calling
I love that call let's go to Ryan next
who joins us in Raleigh North Carolina
Ryan how can we help
hey again Rachel thanks for having me um
I have a couple questions me and my wife
are going to be building our first home
soon by the end of the year and we are
considering doing a first lean key lock
instead of a traditional mortgage
um
why you know just wanted to uh
it would give us the ability to pay it
down and you know five to seven years
maybe if we can be aggressive and
putting all of our finances towards it
and I just think it would be you know
how would you do that walk me walk me
through that
so basically and my dad kind of got me
on this because he refinanced several of
his properties that he had at three
percent into you know he locks and uh
we would just be putting like all of our
direct deposits towards the you know
into the homes value to
uh pay that down aggressively but why do
you need a first lean HELOC to do that
well you tell me why would it why would
that not well the first lean HELOC I
mean a helix taking Equity out of your
home and borrowing against your house
the first lean HELOC there's I mean I
guess unless you put down a down payment
that you're you're taking the HELOC out
of out of the front end not the back end
or so I don't know let me just tell you
this Ryan
he locks to me equal risk you're
basically borrowing against your house
and if something were to happen your
guys are gonna you lose your house if
you can't pay it so in my opinion well I
guess well you could do that too it's a
mortgage but like so yeah well wait a
second you're going to get a fixed
mortgage versus a HELOC is a variable
rate are you familiar with that
absolutely but uh but what you know if
we're if we're
we're all of our money into the home you
know because we have no if we're putting
extra how much money do you guys have to
put down on a mortgage
uh or a building are you doing are you
doing a building loan are you doing a
construction loan construction loan yep
how much will that be for
the 350 000 is going to be the full loan
value but we have 135 000 in cash
yeah yeah you're basically borrowing
against that Ryan
here's the deal Ryan you don't even
understand why you're doing it when I
challenged you on it and said uh why
wouldn't you just put all of your money
into paying off the house through a
traditional mortgage principal yeah
towards the principal and you went uh I
don't know why would I so I appreciate
your dad's influence on your life he's a
good dude uh but you don't even
understand it you can't even explain it
to me so you could pay the house off in
seven years uh then pay it off at seven
years I don't know why you need to
borrow against yourself it just seems
like you're doing some crazy math
gymnastics or your dad is and you don't
even understand it so the advice we give
to people is is is to put uh is to put a
big chunk down in a 15-year Mortgage and
pay it off after you've taken care of
all the other debt in your situation you
guys have no debt but the house so put a
big down payment down and pay it off in
a 15-year mortgage and you're gonna be
free and you're not doing any gymnastics
but that's what we teach but if you
don't understand this other option that
you're bringing to us we would tell you
don't do anything
do you understand the first lean HELOC
versus a traditional HELOC what the
difference is
uh yeah I mean traditional you're
borrowing against your home's Equity but
this first lien we won't have a mortgage
so we'll be able to put you know all of
our income into the house and how it
operates is we're able to take you know
Equity out for to pay our groceries no
no that's terrible Brian no no
if you lose your if you lose your uh job
Ryan then it's like oh my gosh you can't
pay for your living you can pay for for
nothing it's like and then you're you're
risking your own house at that point
because you're borrowing against the
equity and then you and then it's not
worth what it was worth so it it's a
that's a messy game I would not do that
not play that but hey that's our take I
think you're going to do what you want
to do this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
let's go to Preston who joins us now in
Dallas Texas Preston how can we help
hey how's it going Ken thank you uh
thank you all for having me this morning
sure uh I you know I'm a uh a married
guy with three kids uh we got a good
income of about 185 190 000 a year but
it seems like we are hemorrhaging money
through our miscellaneous budget item
and our our food item uh you know we've
got one car loan we've got about twelve
thousand dollars left on that I've got
some medical debt we had a child this
year so we've got about six thousand
dollars there
and then we've got uh just some student
loans left over uh that amount to about
4 500 and then a mortgage that's about
200 000 left uh so total debt is about
222 000 uh we make you know 185 190 and
it feels like at the end of the month we
just have nothing left
um I really just kind of wanted to get
some insight on what should the family
spend uh you know monthly in a
miscellaneous item uh maybe in in the
food budget but we are just spending
pretty much what we earn and you know
we've gone up in salaries over the last
five years tremendously we've doubled
what we make but we're still spending
everything we make and so I cannot
figure out how to get over that hump
yeah it's that it's the classic
lifestyle creep right it's just a little
bit here and there and over time that
starts to become your norm and then you
just add a little bit more add a little
bit more and then you look up and you're
exactly yeah what you're saying
um president are you guys doing a very
detailed budget
very detailed I am in accounting which
is kind of ironic but I'm not good at
accounting for my own expense expenses
uh but you know we we set a food budget
of let's say 1500 to 2000 a month and
then you sit there and go hey we just
spent three thousand dollars on food uh
and you sit there and go how are we
doing that well uh as as George would
would like to not hear we eat out all
the damn time yeah that's it I mean
yeah yeah let's just let's go out to eat
it's easier I know and we all know that
that we're going to spend way more there
than we do at home but yeah it's really
just frustrating to be
well there's no that's what's hard about
this Preston is with personal finance we
always say it's it's 80 Behavior it's 20
head knowledge so you have the head
knowledge of the numbers down with the
budget of here's what we're gonna do but
then you guys are not living on the plan
that you've created you're going over a
thousand dollars in food you're throwing
you know a few hundred bucks here or
there throughout the month on all this
other stuff
um and so when you when you realize that
it's more of a discipline problem with
you guys and the choices that you're
making in everyday expenses it is it's
it's stuck in the the life out of out of
y'all what I would do Preston I would
challenge you guys
to say
um and you know if you hold on the line
I'm going to give you uh the premium
version of every dollar because I think
every dollar is one of the most helpful
budgeting tools because it's going to be
able to connect to your bank and you're
going to be able to really be able to
see in the way they do the paycheck
planning and everything it's just it's a
it's a really well easy thing to see and
your wife can have the same login so you
guys both have the app on your phone
and I would practice Preston acting like
you guys make 80.
okay act like you're like you're making
80 Grands and do a budget off of that
and just see what see what happens say
okay we then that means we have to way
cut back here that means these you know
18 subscriptions we're paying for we
can't do that uh that means maybe the
kids that are doing the fun Little Gym
classes every two days a week they're
not going to do that anymore like you
will have to cut back because I want you
to take that 80 grand or more
quote-unquote I'm kind of just using a
random number but I want you pay enough
the student loan the car loan I mean all
these loans that you guys have beside
your mortgage you guys could get this
knocked out so quickly and what I love
about this we always just call it
gazelle intense because it is deep
sacrifice you are running like your
hair's on fire and it's like it is
scorched Earth it's like we're doing
nothing we're doing nothing and we're
cutting back and so that means maybe
even cutting back more than 80. I was
just saying as a fun mathematical game
on the budget just look to see what you
would cut start there and then I would
trim back as as much as you guys can
Preston because I want you guys to feel
progress with your money and it feels
like you're spinning your wheels you got
all this debt hanging around you're
living still paycheck to paycheck and
there's been no progress and so in order
to get these wins like there's some
stuff and lifestyle that you will cut
and it'll hurt it will not be fun and I
know with a new baby it's like you guys
are all exhausted I get it this is the
time to do it to buckle down and say
it's now or never it's for a short
period of time because then when all
that's gone Preston I mean how much is
going out in payments for this debt per
month besides your mortgage do you have
that how much is going out just to debt
I do so for our medical debt we actually
we've got a a high deductible insurance
plan so we've got an HSA that I've got
that set up to to wipe that out in the
year uh to where you know that doesn't
hang around so that's automatically off
the top and then we've got my watch car
loan uh that we pay about 2500 a month
on it holy crap what kind of car is it
you're taking some chunks at this well
if you're paying extra you're paying
extra oh okay it's only 500 bucks okay
okay
I think we've got more in the budget uh
but
you know we just once we get to the end
of the month to to make an extra payment
uh it's not there and it's just super
frustrating
yeah I mean it's because you're living
like you're making 190 and spending
everything so yeah so let's just look at
this what's your what's the smallest
debt that you have
uh that'd be the the uh the student
loans uh you know we've got three of
them for the Sallie Mae loans but they
total about 4 500 bucks okay so instead
of focusing
car loan focus on the student loan yeah
and go ahead and just get that knocked
out what's the payment what's the
minimum payment on the student loan
right now the three of them together
if they're all out and that's the bad
deal is you all know they're in
forbearance so we haven't even been
paying on them we've been just chunking
at her car loans and I know that's not
what baby step two is uh for that
gazelle intensity okay
here's a point I'm trying to make if you
stay with us if you stay with us and you
work this plan you guys cut first of all
you need to stop eating out like no more
like you guys got to stop you gotta eat
turkey sandwiches at night get do eggs
and bacon and for dinner I mean like you
can do cheap meals right for a season
it's not forever you're an accountant
your issue is not the numbers the issue
is the behavior and if you guys try it
for one month and go you know what we're
all in we're not going to eat out one
time at all just to see how much money
you can save extra
and the point is we knock out the
student loans then we knock out the car
payment all of a sudden you've got more
margin than you realize here's the I
know you're discouraged but you've got
more margin in that budget than you
realize but you've got to change your
spending habits and if you do that and
if we can get some extra income we sell
some stuff in this debt snowball
whatever we got we can find margin
pretty quickly it's as detailed As You
Are
grasping the numbers you and your wife
have got to sit down and go if we do
this and then we do this and we do this
like crazy for the next six 12 months
here's how much progress we'll make and
then all of a sudden you go oh this is
doable I think you're just discouraged
right now and Preston with with I'll add
on that for Ken because this is always
helpful for me whenever we're doing a
big goal so whether for you it's getting
out of debt or you know it's saving up
for something look at the time frame run
the numbers like what we're saying and
just know and say okay we're confident
you know it's July right now so we are
confident you know by dang Christmas
we're gonna be we're gonna do it from
now till Christmas it's just it's go
time or whatever the the date is but
have that date because that gives you
the the light at the end of the tunnel
that you're not going to like live in
this world forever and ever amen you can
actually enjoy what you're working but
you're not enjoying your money now
because again I think so much of it is
this debt and so much of it is that
lifestyle because once you guys pay this
off do you have any savings at all
Prestons you guys have cash in the bank
yeah we have some but not enough to to
cover any of it how much
we've got our emergency fund just to
start emergency funds okay so you got a
thousand dollars that's where you're at
yeah can you sell your wife's car
we get we're running out of time but I
mean you got to look at everything man
selling cars everything you know you're
gonna reduce your monthly payments and
increase your income so for you my
friend I know you're an accountant but
there's a lot of gig work right now for
accountants I'd be working 60 80 hours a
week doing accounting work because you
can get paid very well for freelance
work income goes up expenses go down
that's good that's not quick like get
after it and then you'll see some
breathing room and then you realize okay
we can stay the course thanks for the
call you'll get there Preston this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
all right
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz
thrilled that you are with us this hour
our scripture of the day comes from
Hebrews 6 11. we want each of you to
show the same diligence to the very end
so that what you hope for may be fully
realized our quote today from Arnold
Palmer for some of you you just think
that's a beverage it's a he was a man a
great call for one of the greatest
golfers of all time the road to success
is always under construction I love that
yeah it feels like every road in America
is as well well it's a separate issue uh
today's question of the day is sponsored
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
to repair maintain or improve your home
researching dozens of providers is a
thing of the past neighborly is all you
need to remember for a nationwide
network of local home service pros visit
neighborly.com to find help near you and
today's question comes from Sarah in New
Mexico what are some things that you do
to make fun memories as a family without
spending money or going really cheap
that's good I actually have one after
all you're the expert on all that stuff
but go Ken what's yours well I'm so I've
got teenagers now yes and game night
that was going to be mine ours is Jenga
right now board games has been great we
introduced the oldest Thai you know Tai
he's very cynical and we kind of forced
it we're like this is happening like you
can go out with your friends yes but
we're going to do this
and we taught him how to play Clue the
classic you know crime keeper was it
Colonel Mustard in the kitchen yes and
he just had the worst attitude about it
and about 20 minutes in guess who was
the most enthusiastic it was Ty so you
know the classic board games is really
fun and that costs zero money and again
I'm talking teenagers now great memories
when they were little I will tell you
going to local and state parks
feeding ducks playground time that costs
you zero money and as a parent you're
you're remembering all those things so
those are two that stick out to me yes
oh I love that yeah I was gonna say game
night because my kids they're old enough
now to do like the memory game oh love
them Jingo all that kind of stuff but um
yeah I'd say that I mean we do stuff
around our neighborhood I'm like if you
know we have a we have a pool in a
community pool in our neighborhood uh I
don't know everyone does but for us I'm
like that's a night around you're paying
the HOA before it I guess it might as
well right but using that we do we do a
lot of walks the girls will scooter bike
and uh Charles is old enough now no
stroller so we're just we'll do we'll do
night walks we'll do stuff in the
driveway I'll go to Big Lots and get
just some like cheap summer stuff
sidewalk chalk badminton stuff I mean
like just really cheap things and they
love it I'm like so it's amazing
um how much and I'm sure and I know the
teenagers are the same way Ken
how much they just want to be with you
yeah and and even this morning as I was
like getting ready and coming here and
Charles was like Mommy look at me look
at me and I realized I had been on my
phone doing stuff and I was like oh yeah
and so I'm like they just want you and
so yes is Disney World fun it's all like
extravagant stuff sure absolutely but
man the the quality of time that your
kids wants you don't have to do a time
do a puzzle like whatever it is but it's
it's amazing there's another one they
want that quality time there's a cheap
one all right uh and this comes from the
lower middle class Coleman family when
we were growing up my dad wouldn't buy
the wet banana or the slip and slide
whatever it was called back then so he
went and got a big sheet tarp like a
tarp yeah and we he just got the garden
hose out oh yeah and that's in the
backyard one of the most fun memories
I've ever had we used to do it all the
time it costs you no money other than a
little of the water bill yep but it's a
great memory and everybody's slipping
and falling you know the grandparents
out there and they bust it the kids love
that that's kind of fun got to be
careful though we don't want hip
replacements yeah
medical expenses so be careful but the
old homemade slip and slide you know
that's always great fun garden hose and
some cheap uh yes and I think just
getting out and Yeah and doing stuff we
have friends and they have kind of like
a farm-esque setup and my kids would
stay out in their backyard with their
chicken everything for hours hours love
it are you doing the chicken coop uh
they're in the face no we're not but I'm
not against it yeah I I'm we have a big
Garden so I'm all for it I just want to
get the eggs from somebody else I don't
want the mess in the background I know
you know my problem would be the rooster
at five in the morning but you don't
have the rooster I know you don't have
to but that's kind of traditional you
kind of want to do the whole thing don't
Farm no you don't want to do the rooster
no just the layers just give us yeah
just give me another chicken just go for
the eggs all right I get it I thought I
would do the whole thing you know I get
it I get it you don't need the rooster I
understand I'm gonna get all kinds of
comments about that but but anyway
nonetheless I think it's kind of fun to
have him walking around and it's true
I'm I get it all right totally I digress
Zach is on the line in Alberta Canada
Zach how can we help
hey guys thanks so much for taking my
call today you bet what's up
so um I'm a heavy equipment operator for
a commercial construction company that's
had some really great steady growth and
uh they pay me they pay me well
um to operate equipment I kind of gross
around 80 to 85 000 a year working for
these guys
um
uh and I just had a conversation here
earlier in and basically they wanted to
offer me a foreman position promotion
which is a job I've done before but
um you know it's great it's just there's
a lot of added stress and time
constraints surrounding your job versus
operating the gear
um the second part to this question is I
have a side hustle that's kind of a
passion slash hobby I uh I build and
repair guitars and uh you know that
that's really great it kind of gives me
an income around 500 to 1200 a month and
I just continue to kind of circle and
cycle that back into that obvious like
buy more tools more cooking that kind of
stuff and so I guess the question that I
have today is you know if I go for this
promotion I'm going to get faster
through baby step two
um but I'm going to take away from my
side hustle which is a passion so I
guess I'm kind of caught here because I
you know my wife and I have been
committed into the plan we paid sixty
thousand dollars in Consumer Debt in the
last 12 months nice
um so we're pushing hard and we want to
continue to push hard but I guess we're
kind of Crossroads here where I might
have to stop and hang up this this side
hustle that I love doing how much uh how
much debts you guys have left
so with twenty seven thousand dollars
twenty seven thousand five hundred and
forty and change all right so here's the
deal I can hear in your voice you do not
want to be a foreman
is this true
yeah I had a I had a real bad run
um was the last time that I did it good
um no need to explain no need to explain
you don't want to do it I could tell I
could hear it all over you and you
really really love this guitar side
hustle and the fact of the matter is if
you didn't keep pouring the money back
into it for the tools and you did what
you did to get to this point you could
get out of debt even faster I'd stop
investing in the guitar business and any
money I made from the guitar business I
didn't I'd put it into the debt snowball
and you can get out faster I would say
no to the promotion and uh and just tell
them you know what I don't want to be in
leadership I didn't have a good
experience before and I'm really happy
operating the Machinery that's a good
eighty thousand dollar base that'll keep
you stable and then eventually if you
build this side hustle up to where
you're making 80 000 you step into that
but I think the answer is no to being
the foreman and I would just stop
reinvesting the guitar side hustle money
I'd put that in the debt snowball and
you're out of debt even faster true
yeah yeah I know that's a great point
but hey that's what I think I'm hearing
how do you feel yeah did that feel like
a huh that felt good when Ken said that
and gave you permission to stay where
you are
yeah it does feel good I I think that
where where my brain goes is you know I
I was in we'll call it two years ago
when I was a foreman
um and I was amassed in all this
Consumer Debt because my wife's a saint
and it wasn't her it was definitely me
um and I just think back to how I had
vowed to really put effort into dealing
with this with this debt but also not
just you know giving up on growing
growing a dream on behalf of my on
behalf of my kids because the economy is
getting crazy you're trying to talk
yourself into that this is a good idea I
think you feel guilty for not taking a
promotion
that's what I think yeah I think but you
should think that I do but Zach you're
not you shouldn't feel guilty you
shouldn't feel guilty at all you've done
the hard work you don't owe your wife or
anybody taking a job that you're going
to be miserable in just because you said
you do everything you can go fix more
guitars go get a side hustle over there
if you want to do more but don't take
this promotion you're going to end up
regretting it I promise you're fine
you're gonna be out of debt before you
know it do exactly what I said before
and I think you're gonna feel better and
you're gonna have a better relationship
everything's gonna be better my friend
you're gonna be out of debt so don't
take this promotion Rachel Cruz great
hour thanks for hanging out Ken as
always Austin our fearless leader and
the crew behind the glass thank you all
and you America thanks for listening
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsey win go to ramseysolutions.com
today to sign up for our newsletter
again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]